welcome back fair for another discussion
about the business of containers happy
to be back Marty what are we talking
about today in today's episode I will
share what I've learned from it decision
makers about their container journey and
what they wish they had no before they
got started sounds great
[Music]
do it decision makers know and care
about containers yes they like
containers because it helps them with
four things technical debt multi-cloud
localization and hiding right the last
video you and I shot together went into
more detail about that I'll link to it
in the description anyone who wants a
description of why containers matter to
the business people they should watch
the video but today we are talking about
when you have decided that containers
are the right path forward for your
organization then how do you get started
moving your business applications to
containers in the cloud is a big step
where do you even start you start with
where you are today and where you want
to go here's a map many organizations
are not using containers and they are
not in the cloud so they start in the
bottom left box and I want to go to the
top right box that's right in the top
right box you get the benefits of both
the cloud and containers
all right so if my organization is in
the start box how do I get to the goal
box there are three ways to get there
the first one is lift and shift you move
your existing system to the cloud as it
is now and how does that help you when
your system is in the cloud it will be
easier to manage it if a server's power
supply or network card breaks your cloud
provider will replace it you don't have
to do that anymore
and looking at the grid it looks like
lift and shift is the first step toward
your goal that's right the next step is
containerize your workload when you've
done that you get all benefits of being
in the cloud some people call this move
and improve this method is useful if you
need to move to the cloud as soon as
possible it's also a good one if you are
still building out devops practices and
culture in your organization
but you are not quite there yet I
imagine this two-step process gives you
a good time to evaluate to after the
first step right when you have done the
lift and shift it is optional to
containerize you might choose not to
controlize some workloads like databases
and backups sounds good your grid
implies that there is another path to
the cloud yes you can choose to
containerize your applications first
before you move to the cloud by doing
that you get safer deployments and
easier measurement in your existing Data
Center
why would I want to stay in my existing
data center perhaps you are in a
multi-year contract with your existing
data center provider or you have just
made a major capex investment in new
servers and you need to amortize that
for a while longer or there may be
security concerns about moving to the
cloud that will take some time to sort
them out in all these cases you don't
want to move to the cloud right away but
you want to be ready when the time comes
and you get simple deployments while you
are doing that prep work
and when the time comes you move your
container as workload to the cloud right
this move will be much easier because
you did most of the heavy lifting in the
previous step that all makes sense
depending on where my organization is in
terms of devops culture contracts
capping investment and so on I will pick
the path to the cloud that's right for
me that's right but that is a third way
you can containerize and migrate all at
the same time wow that sounds audacious
but I like how it's fewer steps this
path is right for you if an application
is under active development and you want
to reap the full benefits of the cloud
sooner when you've made this move you
have a faster time to Market
what types of applications would be good
for this approach smaller applications
that are changing often for example your
company's website or evolving systems
that use microservices and modern
architectures that makes sense Fair
thank you for giving us another insight
into the business of cloud computing and
containers have to help
and thank you everyone for watching if
you have questions for fair or me please
add them in the comments also do let us
know if there are other topics you'd
like to hear about in future episodes
until next time
[Music]